recently Australia got to see a total
lunar eclipse this is when the earth
gets between the Sun and the moon and
the shadow of the earth is cast on the
moon turning it dark and red I was able
to go and see the lunar eclipse with
some of my friends and it actually got
me thinking about the topic of being an
expert was on something or at least
being perceived as an expert so back and
I guess a previous life of mine when I
was an undergrad in New Zealand I was
involved in an urban astronomy group we
would take telescopes out onto the
street and I would show members of the
public through the telescope and answer
their questions about space and about
astronomy I guess during that time I
would have been expected to be an expert
on things like a lunar eclipse phases of
the Moon and how all of that is working
and being in that role gave me a lot of
confidence to answer questions on that
topic even if I didn't totally
understand them I felt a level of
confidence - I guess Reis a explanations
that I'd heard other people give or to
say something that I knew made physical
sense enough so that it would satisfy me
and satisfy the person asking the
question even if I did have some of my
deeper like questions myself about how
this was working I wouldn't really raise
them because I was expected to be in the
role of answering the questions not
asking them when I went up to watch the
Eclipse the other week I didn't really
tell these friends I was with about that
you know experience that I had with
telescopes and stuff and I just sort of
took a backseat role of letting someone
else in the group stand up as that
expert and answer our questions about
how the Eclipse was working because I
still had things I didn't totally
understand and that I wanted to know
more about so I found viewing the
Eclipse to be really fun because I was
able to ask questions things like you
know how much darker is the moon going
to get and how long is it going to laugh
and which countries can see it right now
and I don't think I would have felt
confident asking those questions if I
had been in the role of the expected
expert I think it was only yeah from
that backseat role I was able to really
engage my own curiosity instead of
standing on I guess a pedestal and just
regurgitating explanations that I had
sort of heard or read on the internet or
something and I don't know when this
sort of thing started but it's
definitely something I've faced a lot in
my life as being that expected expert in
a topic like way back in high school
people who knew in my class and my
teachers that I had quite an interest in
physics and astronomy and even back then
like the teachers would maybe pick on me
to answer a question about some obscure
astronomy thing and I probably wouldn't
know the answer but I would feel like I
had to like I was responsible for
knowing all the physics and astronomy at
that age even though that's quite absurd
for anyone to ever know all of the
subject I would feel that just because
my peers and my class expected me to be
tobe the person there knows stuff about
physics and astronomy that if I didn't
know the answer it was sort of shameful
and that I didn't really feel
comfortable as much as I should have
asking other people in my class
Christians about physics because I was
the one who was expected to be the
expert on this and not them and it's
quite a dangerous mindset to just stop
your own questions in your own curiosity
because you are suddenly expected to
know more about it than other people
like even going on through uni and then
I graduated with a physics degree it
still sort of hampers me in a way
because when I'm with people I'm afraid
that if I ask too many perceived dumb
questions about physics they will look
at me and think like how did you get
your physics degree like as if I have a
lack of confidence and the worthiness of
my physics work and of my physics degree
that if I ask too many damn questions I
didn't deserve it
and like I said I think it's quite
damaging to be in that role like I do
have the degree which means I do know
some stuff about physics but I still
think it's absurd for anyone to think
that they know all of physics and there
are going to be mistakes that I make in
explanations and things I don't
understand but yeah I feel like I need
to gain more confidence in asking the
questions despite my qualifications
I think someone with the qualification
who holds that up has meaning that you
should trust them and everything they
say is a bad thing because your
qualification shouldn't really give you
so much
superiority over other people it should
represent that you have at least proven
you know a base level of things but I
don't think there's anything that really
proves that you should trust every word
someone says I think you should always
and a question people with
qualifications and people with
qualifications should ask questions of
everyone else I get how saying this
could also be damaging in the other
direction like you you want people who
do have levels of understanding to
sometimes be the ones to stand up and
tell people how something works and you
want people to believe in scientists and
believe in people who have gone through
like all the education system and then
actually do you know what they're
talking about because a lot of problems
and science come when people don't deny
facts that scientists try to tell them
and there's this whole mistrust and
science going on so it can be damaging
to say like people with qualifications
shouldn't act like they know everything
because sometimes that confidence is
what they need to do to get important
ideas across but I don't really know the
answer here like I think it's a bit of
both if you're going to have people
without qualifications and without the
education standing up and being the ones
who are confident enough to say listen
to me this is how something works and
you've got all the scientists standing
on the other hand say
ah you know we we're not quite sure in
the science and we're still learning as
well we make mistakes and admitting the
truth and the honesty behind science
then that's going to lead to a really
skewed reality where I guess the wrong
people come into power so I don't think
scientists should be totally like
unconfident and what they're trying to
get across but I think that scientists
and people with any kind of interest or
you know perceived expert level and
something should continue asking
questions and should continue engaging
with people and not let themselves think
that they are on this pedestal where
they are only there to answer questions
and not to ask them as well I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this because it's
not really something I've heard people
talking about before but it's just
something that crossed my mind the other
week when I felt like for the first time
in a while that I could really just ask
questions without being judged so leave
a comment below if you've ever felt a
similar thing to this and I'll see you
next time